5G розповсюджує коронавірус,
буде управляти людським тілом та контролюватиме населення світу.
Фейків та конспірологічних теорій про нову технологію мобільних мереж у світі чимало.
Занепокоїлись і українці.
Блогери Ірина й Іван - серед 25 тисяч українців,
які підтримали петицію проти запровадження швидкісного мобільного зв’язку в Україні.
Подружжя вже кілька років проводить курси з корисного харчування та фізичного виховання.
Мають понад 52 тисячі підписників.
На їхні голоси й розраховували.
Я 100% упевнений, що воно шкідливо.
Так само, як і 3G, і 4G,  і будь-який сигнал з вайфай-роутеру.
Та наразі ми балансуємо між життям у сучасному місті
й між тим, як це впливає на наше здоров'я.
Тому  я вважаю, що наразі не треба гнатись за 5G,
можна розвивати 4G по всій Україні.
У Міністерстві цифрової трансформації дивуються такій позиції українців.
Я не вірив, що ця петиції набере необхідну кількість голосів,
і подумав, що треба, мабуть, більше комунікувати з українцями,
бо це свідчить про дуже недостатній рівень освіченості
про те, як працюють радіохвилі, як працюють технології загалом.
Як працює мобільний зв'язок, для DW пояснює
викладач фізико-технічного інституту "Київського політеху" Павло Наказной.
За його словами, 5G або "п'яте покоління", як і його попередники 3G та 4G,
використовує електромагнітні хвилі в діапазоні радіохвиль.
Вони, на відміну від рентгенівських променів чи ультрафіолетового та гамма-випромінювання,
не здатні проникати через шкіру, тканини та змінювати структуру ДНК,
як запевняють противники швидкісного мобільного зв'язку.
Та довжина і енергія, яку несуть хвилі 5G,
їх недостатньо навіть для розірвання хімічних зв'язків у молекулах.
Це, у фізиці кажуть, неіонізуюче випромінювання. Воно не іонізує речовину.
Тобто максимум, куди може потрапити ця хвиля, -
це поверхневий шкіряний шар, це долі міліметра.
Що ці хвилі можуть зробити, якщо потраплять на шкіру людини?
З простих міркувань, мабуть, що нічого.
Окрім того, додає фізик, за своєю технологією 5G працюватиме, як wi-fi.
Це означає, що відстань між базовими станціями повинна бути не менше 100 метрів.
Такий вид зв'язку не зможе покрити всю країну. Лише великі міста.
Водночас він дасть поштовх для розвитку нових технологій.
Зокрема, в медицині - для дистанційних операцій у реальному часі,
в сільському господарстві - для роботи автоматизованої техніки
чи в місті - для автономного водіння авто.
Відчують переваги й користувачі мобільного зв'язку:
передача даних зросте в рази,
та для українців ці зміни настануть зовсім нескоро.
На разі й 3G не скрізь працює, тож більшість не замислюються, чи має шкідливий вплив 5G.
Більш шкідливе, коли немає інтернету по світу, Києву чи Україні,
по селах і люди не можуть обирати ту інформацію,
яку хочуть, а беруть тільки ту, яку дають.
5G чи 4G - мені здається, особливої різниці немає.
Цивілізація без прогресу не можлива. Тому все необхідно.
Це дуже небезпечна річ, інтернет, насправді.
Тому 3G і 4G, 5G для мене це все….
Людина має зберегти свою самобутність, особливо з дитинства.
Колись і 4G теж писали.. тому коли настане інше G, то буде те ж саме.
Якщо це допоможе ефективніше комунікувати, швидше, то я не думаю,
що це ідеологічно якось відрізняється від 3G і 4G.
У Міністерстві цифрової трансформації поки працюють над покращенням 4G-мережі.
Щодо 5G, то, за оптимістичними прогнозами,
лише наприкінці наступного року можуть відкрити тендери для запуску мережі.
Для цього слід змінити низку законів і підзаконних актів.
Зокрема наблизити українські вимоги до телекомунікаційних мереж до світових стандартів.
Так, щільність потоку випромінювання нині не повинна перевищувати 10 мікроват/см2,
у той час як і в Європі і США він становить від 450 до 900 мікроват/см2.
Такі жорсткі норми перешкоджають розвитку телекомунікації
і наражають українців на небезпеку.
Чим гірший сигнал від базової станції, який залежить від цих норм,
тим більше випромінює телефон, щоб, так би мовити, достукатись до тієї базової станції.
Блогер Іван категорично проти пом'якшення діючих норм.
Після того, як петиція проти 5G набрала необхідні 25 тисяч голосів,
колишній юрист разом із однодумцями продовжує переконувати своїх підписників
у ризиках такої стандартизації.
До 2017 року було до трьох,
з 2017 року, коли започаткували 3G і 4 G, стало 10,
тобто теж збільшили. А зараз хочуть для підтримки бізнесу з 10 до 100.
Для чого це роблять? Щоб підготувати все для будівництва...
Звісно, це будівництво плацдарму для цього.
Дослідження у всьому радіочастотному спектрі,
зокрема і на частотах, які використовують для технології 5G,
проводили і науковці Всесвітньої організації охорони здоров'я.
Згідно з їхніми висновками, рівень радіочастотного опромінення
від сучасних технологій призводить до незначного підвищення температури
в організмі людини, та в цілому ризиків для людини немає.
На сьогоднішній день, згідно з багатьма проведеними дослідженнями,
жодний шкідливий вплив на здоров'я не був зумовлений дією бездротових технологій.
Насправді протистояння проти 5G-мереж у світі
пов’язане не стільки з імовірним впливом на здоров’я людини,
як із захистом  персональних даних та витоком інформації.
Наразі лише кілька компаній у всьому світі виробляють обладнання, необхідне для 5G-мереж.
Серед них - китайські, які пов’язують зі спецслужбами КНР,
тож українській владі, окрім запуску просвітницької кампанії
щодо впливу 5G на організм людини, слід визначитись і з тим,
кого саме допускати на новий ринок мобільних послуг.